tran y est avec nous ce soir donc
s'arrêter battu pendant trois ans par
votre conjoint entre 2012 et 2015
aujourd'hui encore vous êtes victime de
menaces de mort de la part de votre ex
oui c'est exact c'est il vous avez
quitté votre mari en 2015 après qu'il
vous ait battu alors que vous étiez
enceinte de votre fille exact
effectivement donc j'ai foncé on s'est
connus donc pendant deux ans on s'est
mariés et les on est blanc avant de
vouloir y ait plus de violence
non il n'y a jamais rien eu ça vraiment
commencé donc six mois après notre
mariage on est parti vivre à dubaï pour
raisons professionnelles et les menaces
enfin les les coups ont commencé on
commençait au bout de 6 mois donc à
partir de là ça a été des dénigrements
c'est des insultes vous n'avez jamais
été violent avant goût avant non pas du
tout rien si jamais vous êtes jamais
douté verbalement non même verna longue
alors c'est quoi c'est lors d'une
dispute
alors lors d'une dispute mais banal et
que vous étiez déjà disputé avant sur
tellement il y avait rien ou et la fin
je me souvenais pas de avant forcément
enfin y'a rien qui mais il ya eu des
disputes
on va dire banale il faut savoir que
dans les violences n'avaient jamais il
n'y a aucune excuse quand ça a commencé
c'était le on partait à l'aventuré à
dubaï c'était pour du travail
j'étais une moins que rien je ne parlais
pas anglais j'ai je serve à rien enfin
c'était j'étais qu'une mère dès le
premier coup est tombé comme ça donc je
n'avais rien fait il n'y a aucune excuse
ce site est la première fois qu ils vont
fêter la première fois en vous disant
que vous étiez une sous merde que voilà
exactement et j'en ai gardé des
cicatrices de cette première fois la et
durant trois ans a continué et les trois
ans de mariage jusqu'à ce que je quitte
le domicile à ce que je leur art
justement parce que là pendant pendant
six mois il se passe rien liars et
discutent cette première dispute voilà à
dubaï comme vous nous dites c'est la
première fois qu'il a des violences
envers vous et après les violences sont
devenues de plus en plus répétées plus
oui oui parce que finalement l'emprise
elle est là elle s'installe on excuse
moi clairement aux dés dès le départ
j'ai excusé sur fait qu'on était loin de
la famille qu'il était plus diplômés que
moi il ne trouvait pas de travail alors
que moi j'en trouvais qu'il était
bilingue que je ne parlais pas
effectivement anglais mais que j'ai pu
commenter
donc on excuse on rentre dans un la
première fois qu'il a eu des violences
envers vous
s'excuser après non non c'est pas du
tout sur coup ça va être des excuses
après avec des petits cadeaux avec un
restaurant ça va être comme ça c'est pas
dans l'immédiat vous êtes dit quoi ce
moment là quand il a levé la main sur
vous et vous êtes dit sais c'est un
accident bien ses papilles pour lui
c'est un cauchemar mais les accidents
sont le premier et son se répète et en
fait j'ai insisté j'insiste pour avoir
été victime
c'est qu'il ne faut jamais laisser
passer une gifle et même pas une insulte
c'est pas possible homme qui vous aiment
ne peut pas vous insulter et on ne dit
pas suffisamment parce que on tombe dans
une spirale et après il ya les violences
psychologiques qui s'installe les
violences morales et tout ça on ne le
voit pas on peut pas le montrer dès
poussé beaucoup plus facile on a un des
bleus des cicatrices jeter quoi les
violences il vous disait que les
violences morales c'est des mensonges
sur la vie sur notre vie sur notre
mariage mon mariage s'est construit sur
du monstre se fait pour les manceaux
c'était qu'il avait toujours vécu à
l'étranger il m'a fait miroiter plus
quelque chose c'était qu'ils cherchaient
du travail et finalement il faisait bien
autre chose que ça j'ai moi y était avec
eux oui oui j'ai surpris des choses et
qui le par tyler qu'il voyait pas il
faut qu'il travaillait pas mais en fait
je cherchais pas de conneries mais il
était juste avec d'autres exactement
alors moi par contre j'ai toujours
travaillé et faut savoir que je lui
donnais mon salaire je lui donne mon
argent c'est arrivé jusqu'ici donc ce
sont des violences qui s'installent des
cetc permanence et le quotidien en fait
j'ai découvert tout un mensonge
mais durant l' enquête une fois que je
suis parti que je j'ai pas été une fille
une femme en mai valente
une fois que je suis parti parce que
justement je suis tombé à mon mariage
s'est construit sur du mensonge donc
l'âme à
dont j'étais amoureuse en fait
n'existait pas je n'existais pas comme
lui je n'ai pas été ambivalentes
également donc tout de suite tout s'est
écroulé
on vous a dit je ne connaissais pas le
moine oui voilà c'est à dire vous étiez
qu'une personne que vous ne connaissiez
pas aux gars exactement ça vienne tout
autour des clans qui s'en suit voilà